no me arrepiento lo único que lamento es
no haber derrocado a saddam hussein en
estaba en una reunión con el
subsecretario de estado richard armitage
cuando vimos de un avión que se había
estrellado contra el world trade center
y cashman
saneados creímos que se trataba de un
error que un pequeño avión de alguna
manera se había salido de su ruta luego
cuando oímos de un segundo ataque
supimos que algo muy grave estaba
sucediendo
juana yo estaba en mi oficina que
quedaba en la esquina del séptimo piso
del departamento de estado alguien
corrió a contarme que el pentágono había
sido atacado al mirar por la ventana
pude ver las llamas y el humo saliendo
del pentágono es
decir se trataba de algo muy grave yo
debía viajar a londres para reunirme con
mi homólogo ruso eso por supuesto fue
pospuesto
bueno ante todo creo que se trata de un
fallo masivo y grave de la inteligencia
creo que la raíz de todo está en haber
subestimado la amenaza del islamismo
radical de cuan afianzada estaba y de
cuánto habría logrado penetrar y de la
extrema que era gamer words
fundamentalmente sin considerar que este
tipo de ataques era inminente la gente
sencillamente no estaba preparada para
esto ni en shawal jones y en realidad
las agencias de inteligencia no
recibieron advertencias tempranas
bueno no creo que las agencias bajo las
administraciones clinton o buses
tuvieran suficientes detalles
en este land cuando la gente pensaba en
actos terroristas se pensaban en el
secuestro de un avión o ataques suicidas
en medio oriente en si no se contemplaba
la noción de un ataque masivo en eeuu
así como tampoco había informaciones de
inteligencia que lo consideraran
creo que el error más grande fue haber
dejado escapar a osama bin-laden cuando
lo tenían rodeado
creo que fue un error de los militares
al comando que creyeron que los afganos
y otros más cumplirían con sus
compromisos de no dejar escapar ni a
osama ni a ningún otro líder de al-qaeda
y en ese rincón del mundo creo yo se
necesitaban más estadounidenses para
asegurar que eso no fuera a suceder y
ese fue el peor error de la guerra
no creo que haya dejado de serlo desde
la primera guerra del golfo
bajo los términos del cese al fuego los
iraquíes debían supuestamente
desmantelar y destruir todas sus armas
de destrucción masiva
la preocupación por la amenaza iraquí en
la región se mantuvo
si no recuerda las primeras discusiones
durante la primera administración
la idea de derrocar a sadam ya se había
evocado algo que también se discutió en
inglaterra
el punto es que el régimen en sí era una
amenaza para la paz y la seguridad de la
región y esa amenaza existía antes del
11 de septiembre
yo no estoy diciendo que sean hussein
haya tenido que ver con el 11 de
septiembre el era un problema aparte
sumado a afganistán y el grupo talibán
sí creo que eeuu se podía lidiar con
ambos a la vez
no me arrepiento lo único que lamento es
no haber derrocado a saddam hussein en
1991 no no me siento culpable desde mi
punto de vista moral fue la decisión de
estado y una decisión acertada a mi
manera de ver